hey youtubers is Charlie so this week on
Game of Thrones Daenerys totally
reminded us what a badass she is again
already in the Hat are totally hilarious
and totally evil and the aftermath of
the purple wedding gets really really
disturbing so if you're finding me for
the first time real quick I'm doing a
weekly giveaway just to say thank you to
all you guys for being so awesome all
you have to do to participate is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'm gonna announce the winner in
my video tomorrow night so since there's
so much to talk about let's just get
right in it so here my top 5 WTF moments
so careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet but Tywin and
Oberyn come to an arrangement so many
important things we learn from this one
Tywin believes in Daenerys dragons and
flat-out denies any involvement in the
death of Oberyn sister but he only
denies knowledge that had happened not
that someone under him say like the
mountain did it or didn't do it
so when Oberyn agreed to sit on Tyrians
trial he was basically getting that
friendly chat with the mountain and the
seat on the small Council which is a
small change from the books originally
Tyrion had already offered him the seat
on the small council or at least offered
it to his brother
and Oberyn came in his brother's place
it was in exchange for dorrance help
against Stannis during the Battle of
Blackwater just a very minor change
Tyrion kind of called it out later in
the episode when he was clueing for
looks you know Sherlock style Tywin is
essentially trying to use Joffrey's
death to kind of smooth things over with
the Martel's
I'm really just waiting to see what
happens when Oberyn meets the mountain
though that's really what we all want to
see how funny was it though when Tywin
burst in on Oberyn in the middle of that
pile of flesh it reminded me of the time
Tyrion did the same thing in episode 1
there's something about Lannister's
walking in on Oberyn while he's humping
people but I guess it seems like based
on oberyn's earlier speech that every
waking minute until old age should be
spent humping your brains out it was
really nice of Thailand though to call
out the Martel's as the only force that
was able to resist Aegon Targaryen
original conquest of Westeros I actually
wondered if george RR martin posted his
excerpt his Aegon excerpt from the world
of Ice and Fire last week because he
knew this scene was happening this week
let me know if you agree though number 4
Littlefinger helped Sansa escape if you
were clueing for looks into the
tria Joffrey's death I feel like
Littlefinger would just have a red
flashing light plastered on his face he
doesn't outright say he was responsible
for everything but he did point out the
fake Nikolas and the fact that sir
Dontos was only doing exactly what
Littlefinger told him to do so
essentially it would have had to have
been all Littlefinger's planned to
incriminate Tyrion and even if the show
changes a few things from the books I
don't think the whole thing is gonna be
that simple but I think we're gonna get
some more details in the next episode
remember this one detail from their talk
though Littlefinger is always always
reminding Sansa that everyone in the
capital is a liar and then promptly
tells her that she's totally safe with
him and they're heading home so of
course right away giant flashing red
warning lights everywhere just screaming
nope definitely not happening there was
a clip of them in the boat in the next
episode so I think they will show where
he's taking her and did anyone else get
the feeling that Littlefinger was really
laying on the bad man voice a little
thick I mean who would trust someone
that talks like that number three
Daario versus the champion of Meereen so
just a few minor changes from the books
because they cut out a few characters
already but I thought this was an
amazing way to show off Dario's skills
and his humor like they're all just
listing their accomplishments and
Daenerys is like no you're too precious
to fight so Daario is just like I'm a
nobody let me fight him why not I'm
definitely liking the new actor way more
than its grain so I can't wait to see
more of him whatever the story picks
back up did anyone else get an Indiana
Jones vibe you know with the way he took
down that champion especially with the
way he chucked the knife and then turned
around to face the camera like it was no
big deal just like in Raiders of the
Lost Ark so high fives to the riders for
pulling that off in the people that
actually filmed that scene because it
looked amazing and it was really funny
too number two the siege of murine if
you didn't catch it right away she
catapulted all the old slave collars
over the wall as proof of her intentions
that she was going to break their chains
they didn't show a lot of them too but
the quote-unquote masters are actually
just the heads of the slaving families
will probably actually get to meet them
in a future episode we didn't get a
chance to see the unsullied in open
combat last season so seeing them in
formation launching those barrels was
really cool I will be really interested
to see if in the next couple of episodes
they change anything because I think
last season Barristan Selmy called out
sir Jorah as a liar but
this episode Daenerys was calling him
one of her most trusted advisors she was
really laying it on thick too so I'm
wondering if they're trying to
foreshadow something that's gonna happen
between them but Ser Jorah isn't a lot
of scenes that occur inside the city
walls that we saw in the trailer so
clearly he's gonna be with her for quite
a while their ship or their friendship
whatever you want to call it is
definitely still strong definitely much
stronger than Jamie and Cersei and my
number one WTF moment this one was
pretty clear Jamie takes Cersei over
Joffrey's dead body I could spend an
entire video about the many things that
happen in bail or Sept first off that
was the septa where Joffrey got married
last week so that was just a little bit
creepy right away then the burial rites
with the coins on his face and the eyes
drawn on also super creepy but did you
notice that the camera lingered on his
face just like it was forcing you to
look at him so I'll talk about Tommen
and Tywin during bonus moments but we
really need to focus on Jaime and Cersei
I think for the first time I can
remember she openly calls out Joffrey to
Jaime
as their son and then demands he kill
Tyrion then as he is having his way with
her did you notice how when they're in
the middle of all the awfulness
Joffrey's face is clearly visible in the
frame it's just so disturbing
seriously though let me know if you did
not shake your head in disgust at that
scene I just love how Game of Thrones
does such an amazing job of making us
all feel so uncomfortable quick side
note though it also kind of seemed like
Cersei was the only one actually
mourning Joffrey even Tywin called him a
terrible King whenever he was talking to
Tommen so here a couple important bonus
moments that I didn't think we're quite
as important as my top five but that we
need to talk about nonetheless first off
Arya definitely looks like she's losing
patience with the Hound I wonder if
she's just gonna end up sticking him
with needle herself whenever she gets
the chance then Shireen and Davos letter
to the iron bank is also a pretty big
deal that's actually a follow up of
what's going on in that letter Davos is
just trying to get more ships and more
men for Stannis I do think that Mark
Gatiss is getting ready to make his
grand entrance he's actually one of the
members of the bank Sam and Gilly also
super adorable
I really hope those two get a happy
ending but I don't think any one on Game
of Thrones is allowed to have a happy
ending I actually wonder if that's in
George RR Martin's contract you know
no happy endings up at the wall of
course John Sam and maester aemon seem
like the only really smart people but I
do think that they listen to John's
warning about killing those mutinous
nights watch brothers you know to stop
them from helping mance and in case you
didn't remember burn gorman is coming
back this season he's actually one of
those mutinous people that they're
probably gonna end up having to kill but
either way Ygritte and those fins look
really hungry for crow so there is a
battle coming really soon so back to
King's Landing and Tyrion cell did
anyone else get a Tyrion pod Sherlock
Watson vibe Tyrion was totally pulling
off his Sherlock clueing for looks as to
you know who could have killed Joffrey
and who he could call on to support him
which is essentially seems like no one
and then they just had that really sad
goodbye I mean they really are kind of
like a ship all to themselves
this is farewell pod so sideway has
jumped to Tommen in Thailand you know
very important things going on there
Tommen is the new king but let's save
their talk for the comments because that
speech that Tywin actually gave him is
right out of book 3 the speech about the
virtues and the different kings you know
pretty much word-for-word right out of
book 3 but now it's your turn let me
know what was your favorite WTF moment I
know it's so hard to pick just one you
know was it Jaime and Cersei or was it
any one of Danny's marine scenes just so
amazing overall I gave the episode
another solid a I'm kind of actually
worried that I'm gonna end up giving all
the episodes this season and a minus or
better so I'm definitely gonna try and
be a little bit more critical in the
future
but it's really hard to when everything
is just going crazy in the best possible
way I did feel like the Sam and Gilly
scenes were the weakest it feels like
they're just trying to set them up for
their own side story that's gonna
develop across this season if you got a
creepy vibe from that stable he took
Gilly to you were not alone there's no
way she's gonna be safer there I did
love Sam's reaction to other word nope
no other work as for the cinematography
I feel like I already speechify it a lot
of my favorite moments you know Daario
Indiana Jones Littlefinger Shipp did
kind of remind me of something from a
pirate movie with all that fog and
silence on all just totally amazing as
usual as expected
I'll only be rude watching it you know
maybe two more times tonight so let me
know what your final verdict is on the
episode and leave all your questions for
my Q&A tomorrow in the comments below I
think next week my bonus video is going
to be for the Bloodraven since brand
stories coming back
subscribe to get that and feel free to
leave me suggestions for future bonus
videos
in the meantime click here to get that
Q&A I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post the video and click here for last
week's purple wedding video just to
relive the awfulness
you know ding dong the witch is dead
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
high fives
[Music]
you